happy easter everybody it's me kevin
smith uh we're gonna take a look
a mall rats scene study if you will at
the easter bunny sequence
uh you know if you've ever been to a
mall in your life during the holidays
santa easter bunny santa easter bunny so
if you're making them all movie
you better have one of them in there and
mercifully we were making it in the
spring
it was set in the spring mall rats even
though we didn't shoot in the spring so
we got to do the easter bunny you know
in the movie and of course
uh it's you know it seems to be a scene
that has
lived on you know to me it was low brow
[ __ ] low-hanging fruit and [ __ ] but
people love the scene and stuff um you
know two guys beating the [ __ ] out of
the easter bunny i guess it's kind of
funny as kids are like horrified and
[ __ ] like that
um the uh easter bunny if i remember
correctly
uh was bob apisa our stunt coordinator
if i remember
correctly or his friend um
but i know the voice of the easter bunny
is shawn daniel one of our producers
uh the guy responsible for the exec
behind animal house
uh he ran universal for like a decade or
some such [ __ ]
and then him and jim jacks started
alphaville and that was the production
company that viewski teamed up with to
make
mall rats so um i i you know i often
wonder when i watch this scene
did any of these kids like grow up with
scars like i remember being a child and
there were cameras and somebody beat up
the easter bunny
two z grade celebrities whatever
happened to them it's like hey man
we're [ __ ] still doing [ __ ] um
without further ado ladies and gentlemen
the easter bunny scene from all rats
[Music]
all right honey don't forget to look for
your easter eggs on sunday
bye bye easter bunny all right who's
next
hot in this goddamn suit hey guys hey
guys
wait in line like everybody else what
the hell is this this is for brody
hey kids did you like that all these
movies are available on itunes or
netflix in some places
amazon and other places you can find
them they're available
patronize them if you will uh also if
you like this kind of stuff
come on over to that kevin smith club go
to thatkevinsmithclub.com
join up man i do wake and bake three
times a week where i wake up just smoke
weed with y'all and stuff come to that
kevin smith club for more
video antics with kevin smith